OH, YOU LIKE IT,
'CAUSE IT'S GONE. AWESOME.
- LADY IN THE PINK,
DRINK THAT DRINK,
AND PEOPLE, LET'S DANCE, DANCE,
DANCE OUR PANTS OFF.
- ♪ FEELIN', FEELIN',
FEELIN', FEELIN' ♪
- NO, NO, NO, NO!
DERS, PAUSE IT.
- I C--PA--YOU CAN'T--
- JUST DO--IT'S AN iPOD, MAN.
YOU'RE NOT
DOING ANYTHING UP THERE.
- WHA--EXCUSE ME?
- ONE OF THESE STUPID
[bleep] MOMS
POURED ALL MY MOLLY WATER
INTO THE PUNCH.
I'M LEAVING.
I'M DONE.
I QUIT.
THIS IS IT.
- BUT YOU--DUDE,
YOU'RE SAYING ALL THESE LADIES
ARE ROLLING RIGHT NOW.
DON'T YOU UNDERSTAND?
THAT'S THE MOST PERFECT
GROSS DISTRACTION
THAT WE COULD
NEVER THINK OF.
- HOW?
YOU KNOW WHAT?
DON'T TELL ME THE DETAILS.
JUST TELL ME
WHERE I NEED TO DANCE.
- RIGHT IN FRONT OF THE GROUP.
- OKAY.
- THAT'S BE GREAT.
YEAH.
- WHOO!
YOU FEELIN' IT?
ENERGY.
[dubstep music plays]
♪
- ♪ I'M IN LOVE WITH A
♪ I'M IN LOVE WITH A
♪ I'M WITH IN LOVE
WITH A MONSTER ♪
- [bleep]!
♪
- OH, OH, OH, OH!
- OKAY.
- MAGIC MIKE
IN THIS SITUATION.
- THAT'S A LITTLE ROUGH,
PLEASE.
- YOU GUYS FEEL THE ENERGY?
- EVERYONE, ALL RIGHT.
SHOW THAT BABY SOME LOVE.
LET'S B-B-BUMP
THAT BABY BUMP.
- YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, YEAH,
HERE WE GO.
BUMP UP ON THAT BABY BUMP.
YOU GOTTA BUMP UP
ON THAT BABY BUMP.
- BUMP UP ON THAT BABY BUMP.
YEP.
YOU GOTTA BUMP UP
ON THAT BABY BUMP.
- UH-HUH.
- BUMP UP ON THAT BABY BUMP.
- HEY, MONTEZ,
WHERE ARE YOU GOING?
MONTEZ, GET BACK HERE.
WOULD YOU PLEASE
JUST GET OFF OF ME?
- WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- THE MUSIC STOPPED.
- I'M NOT DONE DANCING.
- THE MUSIC STOPPED
AND YOUR DANCING IS A JOKE.
- YEAH, OKAY,
MY DANCING'S A JOKE.
I'LL SHOW YOU A JOKE.
- UP AND OVER. YEP.
- UGH--WHAT?
- MUSCLES FROM BRUSSELS.
RIGHT HERE.
- OH, GOD!
- OH! EW! EW!
YOU SQUIRTED IN MY EYES!
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THAT
COULD HAPPEN OUTSIDE OF PORNO.
- MY WATER JUST BROKE,
YOU IDIOT.